Now, many of you, because this is
a graduate course intended for computer
science, I'm going to assume you've seen
some form of an algorithms class, and
you may have heard that there's
something called a graph cut algorithm.
And a graph cut algorithm
does exactly what you think.
It cuts a graph.
So here I've got a graph and
the idea was originally it had lots of
connections in it, and when I'm all
done, I've decided to break this graph
on those four links to create two s,
different graphs, a and b.
And they're totally d, disconnected, so
those would be two
segments in our image.
And the idea is that the cost
of a cut is quite simply just
the cost of all of
the segments that you broke.
So that's what this thing shows you,
here.
I take, for all of the,
if there's a p in a, and q in b,
and I've separated a and b.
What's the cost between all of those?
And a graph cut would give you
a segmentation of the image.
So the question becomes, what is a good
graph cut, and how do you find one?
So there are algorithms called min-cut
algorithms, sometimes called max-flow
because they're they're duels of each
other, they're the same, that allow you
to find that segmentation in
a relatively not too complex a matter.
Fast min-cut algorithms exist.
So the original min-cut Fulkem,
Fulk, Fulk and
Fulkerson, you may have learned there
are subsequent more rapid ones.
We're not going to go into those here.
All you need to know is that you can
go to your local algorithm store and
buy yourself a good
graph cut algorithm and
the more you can spend the faster
a graph cut algorithm you can get.
And the idea is that,
that would partition your graph.
A problem though,
if we just use min-cut for
doing segmentation, is that
min-cut by definition is going to
try to pull out little segments that
have as few connections as possible.
So what it tends to do, is it tends to
pull off very small little segments.
because by definition a little segment
will only connect to a small number of
other nodes.
So, really what you want to do is
you want to something a little bit
smarter than that.
In an intent,
in fact, what you want to do is what's
referred to as normalized cuts.